Probably
per value value,
valuing,
paying attention and valuing the moment
and realizing that the present is the
most elusive of all,
uh,
that you know,
you can stabilize the past because there
it is.
Or you can at least stabilize instead of
memories and crawl up the past.
You can stabilize the future and that
even though you don't know it,
you can project a future and you can
dream about it.
Um,
or you can just think of it as an object
of curiosity,
but the president is always disappearing
and,
uh,
there are ways to slow down this flood
of time through a,
you know,
just a kind of little meditation or just
looking,
stopping and looking.
Uh,
I think that's the thing I value and
that's what I probably am in that state,
you know,
a half percent of the time.
Um,
but the poetry tries to get into that.
A lot of it does.
Anyway,
I tries to get into that state and
arrest one of those moments.
I have this kind of crackpot analogy,
which is that,
you know,
it,
this is old atomic theory,
but if you took an you've take an Adam
and you smash it,
you know,
um,
uh,
matter is composed of atoms and he
smashed one and it releases this
staggering amount of energy.
Time is composed,
none of Adam's but of moments.
And if you smash a moment,
there is also this amazing release.
And the way to smash a moment is not
with a cyclotron.
Uh,
but through attention you smash your out
by fixing it in your mind.
And,
and uh,
and I think a lot of poetry.
Haiku was a very good example.
Most Little Haiku poems are just
interested in isolating a moment,
but that moment becomes a tiny thing and
suddenly it becomes everything at once.
It's
recovering Catholic.
I went to it to a
jesuit,
I went to,
uh,
I went to Catholic school from the first
grade right through college,
the full metal jacket of Catholic
education when I got to graduate school
is the first time I'd been in a
classroom with a female since the eighth
grade.
So,
I'm not sure of the effect of that on
me,
but,
um,
it's,
I don't have any,
I have,
uh,
I have all the imagery of Catholicism
that's still very vivid and vibrant.
Um,
and,
uh,
the faith is something else.
It's a little,
it's very difficult in a way to maintain
a connection to a church that is so full
of,
uh,
flaws and uh,
and hierarchical.
The structured,
uh,
church,
um,
Martin Sheen I think summed it up best
when he said that.
He said,
I don't believe in God,
but I believe that Mary was his mother.
Uh,
you know,
in other words,
you can,
you can lose contact with the theology,
but you can never lose contact with the,
the iconography,
the imagery,
dre,
decency.
Well,
uh,
courtesy is very much a priority,
but I think I keep going back to
wordsworth,
but he,
he's,
he's suggested are the better part of
our lives.
This sort of thread that connects our
lives is,
is composed of what he calls a little
nameless,
unremembered acts of kindness and of
love.
And it's very important that these acts
are unremembered.
You know,
if you do something consciously for
someone and remember it,
uh,
well,
I mean,
and an endowment is a nice thing to do
and get your name on the gymnasium or
the library.
Um,
that's one kind of contribution,
but I'm equally as important,
I think to t to stitch your days
together,
uh,
is just a kind of moving through the
world with the kind of courtesy.
Uh,
I,
I think that leads to,
it seems almost trivial in terms of
like,
like a point of etiquette,
but I think courtesy leads to a much
bigger things,
but you have to start with
tiny dress.